en Australia más decían edificios y
monumentos públicos se han iluminado de
color púrpura real para celebrar la
ocasión durante el sábado y también se
hará el domingo sin embargo el estado de
Nueva gales del sur cuya capital es
cidney decidió no iluminar sus dos
sitios más emblemáticos la casa de la
ópera y el puente Harbor para evitar
costos esto contrasta con los otros
cinco estados australianos que
decidieron iluminar sus lugares más
emblemáticos sin embargo Ninguno de los
seis estados declaró día feriado para
conmemorar esta coronación la guardia de
la Federación de Australia disparará un
saludo Nacional de 21 cañonazos desde la
Explanada de la casa del parlamento a
las 3 de la tarde del domingo y la real
fuerza aérea australiana realizará un
sobrevuelo el Rey Carlos III ha hecho 16
visitas a Australia la primera fue en
1967 y la última en 2018 el Primer
Ministro de Australia Anthony alvanici a
pesar de que durante toda su vida
política de más años ha impulsado la
idea de que el país se convierta en una
República estuvo en Londres y juró
lealtad al Rey Carlos tercero la última
encuesta disponible hecha por la firma
lord en marzo de este año muestra que el
42% de los australianos está a favor de
convertirse en República mientras el 35%
apoya la monarquía y el 16% está
indeciso otra encuesta de la firma ipsos
de diciembre de 2022 después del
fallecimiento de la Reina Isabel II
concluyó que el 54% de los australianos
apoya a la República mientras el 46%
apoya la monarquía cabe recordar que en
Australia ya hubo un referendo fue en
1999 cuando se le preguntó a la
población si se debía cambiar la
Constitución para convertir el país en
una República en ese momento él sin
resultado de la votación fue que el 54%
de los australianos votaron en contra
del cambio constitucional